sincèrement je sais pas si je suis la
bonne personne dernier gala que j'ai
présentées c'était quand même les césars
sais qui tu es invité thomas vdb
romane freyssinet
car mon isolement
il n'a pas pensé à m'inviter mois ci
mais en fait je me suis dit que je ne
serais pas venu alors est-ce que déjà tu
as pensé un numéro d'ouverture
c'est à dire un numéro d'ouverture
tu vois la réflexion je me demande si tu
as les épaules pour ça d'ailleurs il n'a
pas des pôles du tout c'est très étrange
1 comme tu es
moi je veut bien t'aider mais il va
falloir mettre le paquet
ça
là-bas sur l'étagère hockey
et puis dans les textes soit sincère il
faut
il faut vider son sac
voilà il faut donner ta personne quand
tu présenteras gala il faut savoir
donner de sa personne à la la générosité
c'est important ça pèse toujours sur
scène les traits rien c'est bien pu
c'est très bien ça c'est de la carte
bleue c'est trop ouf tu sais je crois
vraiment 4 tout seul tu peux tu peux
dépoussiérer le genre voilà c'est des
poussières ces dépouilles de poussière
il surtout par sa soudaineté équipe un
bien fou n'est pas ce que ça j'y arrive
pas ça fait mal aux mains
bon
je comprends rien
c'est bon là je crois que j'ai pris non
tu n'es pas prêt il te manque encore
quelque chose pour devenir un vrai
maurice
[Musique]
c'est donc ça la bataille en belgique
non du tout ça fait un pendentif qui m'a
coûté un pot du cube n'est pas ma taille
correcte il ramène à la boutique
d'accord